[Music]
hi
[Music]
so
the last time we caught up i was in the
southwest camping in a few new spots
exploring trails and getting out on
adventures utah in the spring is one of
my favorite places to be
the weather is perfect and there's so
many beautiful views
plus camping is easy and in most places
crowds are minimal
before utah i was pet sitting in durango
which is something i do
fairly often here and there to break up
long stretches of travel on the road
and to be honest i'm not sure i'd still
be out here if it weren't for those
breaks
[Music]
hey guys i'm christian schaefer i'm an
outdoor adventure photographer
and i've been living in my van full-time
for almost three years
so if you've been following for a little
while then you might remember a couple
months back i put out a video talking
about some of the struggles i've been
experiencing on the road
and just wanting to take a break well
right now i'm filming from jackson
wyoming and this is my new temporary
home
so around the one year mark of living on
the road i was living in my suv
and i just started to experience burnout
i would find myself scrolling airbnb for
week-long stays
month-long stays i even spent some time
apartment hunting in washington
and i was just kind of getting tired of
living on the road
i wanted some more stability so that's
when the idea of
pet sitting and house sitting came up
and it did take me a little while to get
that first
pet sit because i didn't have any
references and then after that it took
time to build experience and references
but it's been a two-year journey and
it's been so rewarding
and that's actually what i'm doing here
in jackson wyoming
i'm here for two whole months and i'll
be watching after an adorable wheaton
terrier named jack
and this is the longest set i've ever
done and i'm just really excited to be
here
also the owners are really rad jenna and
colin they're actually spending two
months at base camp in mount everest and
colin is attempting to climb mount
everest without supplemental oxygen
and then he'll be doing another high
peak immediately after that so
pretty badass we got this amazing van
taking us to the airport the airport
shuttle
ride ever i know that staying in a house
isn't
technically van life but house setting
has been
really helpful in keeping me out on the
road long term so
i just thought i would share this with
any of you who might be interested in
this lifestyle
so in general i have a sip booked every
two to three months
and they typically last one to two weeks
some of the longer ones have been three
weeks
and at first i found them through sites
that i signed up for
and now it's a mixture of that and also
just personal references and networking
i always tell myself during these days
especially the longer ones that i'm just
gonna like relax and unwind but that
almost
never happens usually my time is spent
tackling the many
to-do lists that are just kind of tricky
to do from the road
and there are a lot of van chores that
are so much easier to do from the house
for example
deep clean of all these dishes um
if you guys watch my van tour then you
know i don't actually have hot water
in my van so i do my best to clean it
when i'm on the road but whenever i get
a chance to run my stuff through a
dishwasher i
fully do that scheduled maintenance for
the van like oil changes
tire rotations factory recalls broken
windshields
washing the bedding and couch cushions
washing the floors
climbing up onto the roof to clean the
solar panels
pouring enzymes down the sink to keep it
from building up bacteria
cleaning dead bugs off the fan vent just
took this
thing off it's pretty gross gonna clean
that inside
and then just cleaning each of these
blades
they get pretty grimy clearing out and
wiping down the fridge
cleaning the toilet my personal favorite
so fresh
so clean applying fresh coats of finish
to the countertops
cocking the tile and trim and then there
are the usual chores like
washing the van filling the water tanks
filling the propane
and restocking supplies and that's just
the van stuff
so here's another great thing about
having a house to stay at
is when i have product shipments and
jobs i need to do
i have a lot of packing materials that i
have to get rid of and that'd be really
hard to do without a house
as a staging area besides all of that
there is washing the laundry
charging all of the electronics updating
software
uploading large files over wi-fi lining
up product shipments
ordering things online backing up hard
drives
um taking inventory of things in the van
i no longer need
sorry that's jack and and taking them to
a donation center
and forwarding my mail do you need to go
outside
[Music]
click
okay what was i talking about oh yeah
all the different things that
you have to do when you're staying at a
house um the most important thing of
course
is looking after the pets and it's my
favorite thing about
pet sitting is because i don't have a
dog on the road
and i just love animals so
house sitting and pet sitting gives me
an opportunity to spend some time with
them apart from the really long to do
list
the things i really look forward to are
just re-establishing
healthy routines and making space for
creativity and
contemplation relaxing
[Music]
[Music]
on the road so much of my time is just
devoted to planning routes around
photo shoots weather and product
shipments every day i have to think
about where am i going to sleep where am
i going to use the bathroom
where am i going to find wi-fi do i have
enough food propane and water
at least once a week i have to think
about where am i going to shower where
can i buy groceries and where can i
empty my trash
and empty my toilet and grey water tank
when i'm out on the road my mind is just
always in motion just keeping inventory
of these things taking steps to be safe
and in addition to these things i'm also
running a photography business from the
road
a lot of people call this lifestyle
living the dream including myself i love
living on the road
but it is not a walk in the park like
you have to put in the work
to keep this going for any length of
time if you're anything like me
that means you might need some breaks in
order to have balance so
this is my current reality living in a
beautiful corner of wyoming
with the world's cutest dog soaking up
some quality home time before hitting
the road again in june just in time for
summer
and getting out on some adventures in
the grand tetons and yellowstone
last fall i spent about three weeks
around jackson
and it was so beautiful i actually never
got around to sharing it so i'll show
you some of those clips here
i'm really excited to see how it looks
in spring this time around
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so that's a little update and i actually
have a couple ideas for future videos um
but i'd love to hear in the comments
below which one you guys are most
interested in
i was thinking of putting together a
video about finances
um maybe how much i spend on a monthly
basis
while living in a van versus what i used
to spend in an apartment
maybe if any of you are interested in
this lifestyle you might get an idea of
how much you could save
and also just expenses to look out for
that you might not be aware of
another idea is a more in-depth video on
parking i touched on this topic briefly
but i was thinking i might do something
more in depth about
the experiences i've had the resources i
use
run-ins with cops things that will just
help you
find safe places out there on the road
because i know that was the number one
question i had before i moved into my
suv and also i would love to do an
updated van tour
so june of this year will be two full
years in the van
so i was thinking i might show you guys
an overview of what things i have
changed what things i
love what things i wish i had changed or
would do differently
um and just share some of the things
that have been working really well so
that's it thank you guys so much for
watching i hope you're all doing well
and quick housekeeping note if you want
to support me i've put
links down in my caption below to my
website and
there i have gear recommendations van
life essential recommendations
camping gear recommendations as well as
a lot of common questions like
what kind of van do i have how much did
it cost who built it
how i got started with photography all
of that stuff in one place i get a small
kickback every time you use those links
so
thank you so much i really appreciate
your support and i will see you next
time
or sooner if you find me over on
instagram
bye mr jack
you are so cute
you're so cute